Based on the terrible books from one of the
sh*ttiest authors of all time,
comes a movie adaptation for teenage girls
who aren't smart enough for The Hunger
Games.
You'll be on the edge of your seat as voice-over
describes everything.
"I would miss my harebrained mother."
"I used to spend two weeks there almost every
summer."
"My first day at a new school."
Kind of like a book, actually.
"My dad's Charlie."
This catatonic teenager will fall for the
world's gayest vampire.
A film that teaches young girls that the only
thing that matters is finding a man...
a 100 year old man.
"So, how long have you been like this?"
"Since 1918."
But don't worry, it's not pedophilia because
he looks 17.
Together, they will have the romance of a
lifetime
expressed entirely in stares.
[dramatic music]
And even more stares.
A love challenged by the fact that he might
accidentally f*ck her to death,
this special effect,
and her inability to pour ketchup.
A film that conditioned a generation of girls
to think that love is keeping tabs on
each other every waking moment.
"Did you follow me?"
"I feel protective of you."
And even non-waking moments.
"I like watching you sleep."
"Do you do that a lot?"
"Just the past couple of months."
I know this looks creepy, but it's really
romantic in the movie.
I promise.
Starring...
Vanilla
Shovel Face
and Troy Polamalu.
Twilight: it's just a metaphor for abstinence.
Seriously, look it up.
Get ready for an hour and a half of people
standing in semi-circles,
council meetings,
different council meetings,
and sitting
just to get to 5 minutes of cool stuff.